one of the most important modern video
games is about to be six years old and
not nearly enough of us are talking
about it
[Music]
since its release warframe has garnered
almost 50 million players it has
frequented steams most played games list
it has launched on every current console
building an avid community across live
streams and social media alike it's even
hosted a yearly convention for dedicated
players by all accounts warframe should
be in the spotlight but it's not in 2013
warframe was a passion project developer
Digital Extremes had just finished years
of contract work and needed to release
an alpha of its next title to stay
afloat the result was a promising albeit
skeletal build of the studio's sci-fi
loot shooter warframe was also
free-to-play at a time when that label
carried a stigma although players and
critics took note as it released on PC
ps4 and Xbox one
the majority including me quickly moved
on Destiny's Preview coverage was
reaching a fever pitch and comparisons
to bungees loot shooter were unfavorable
for the smaller Digital Extremes lastly
it didn't help that warframe was and
still is very complex it's complex in a
good way and I'll get to that but in its
early hours warframe can be overwhelming
many people reach this screen and decide
they're not smart or determined enough
to decipher it
others are uncomfortable with the
general lack of hand-holding feeling
analysis paralysis in the face of so
many ways to play for any of the
preceding reasons warframe never really
built up the critical attention that
Triple A games often do instead it
quietly improved morphing with each new
update partnering with a community that
helped it prosper it added dozens of
characters introduced to new open worlds
release major story base quests as the
devs often say warframe carved out its
own little pocket in the loot shooter
space the result is one of the more
intriguing phenomenons in modern
videogames a massive successful thriving
title that sites like GameSpot rarely
talked about with so many developers
entering the games as service space and
even more going free-to-play warframe is
now more relevant than ever more
developers should learn from it and if
you ask me we should all be playing it
[Music]
full disclosure I was super late to the
warframe party for years I viewed it
from a distance seeing it as just
another Luke Rhine
too complex to grasp when so many other
games were upfront with their ideas but
three months ago over the holidays I
dove in I've since logged 170 hours I've
collected new characters built better
weapons upgraded hundreds of mods I've
traveled one of the more rewarding
learning curves I can recall and I still
have a ton to learn if you've tried
describing warframe to someone you might
have found it difficult yes it's a
sci-fi action PvE game where you play as
space ninjas in a variety of mission
types but as a loot based game it breaks
the mould titles such as anthem destiny
Diablo and borderlands rely on frequent
trickles of weapon drops from dead
enemies you fight better opponents to
gain better loot allowing you to fight
even better opponents for even better
loot warframe is a grind as well but in
many ways it puts you in control of the
grind you don't gather new equipment in
the field instead you gather the
materials to build the weapon gear or
character you want furthermore you are
in charge of the mods or elemental
effects that would already be fixed to
items in other games in warframe you
have much more say over how your weapons
function than you would in Diablo for
example where you have to respec items
with a dice roll to get a build that you
like it's a shame that the mod system
seems so complicated at first blush
because it's actually one of the more
intriguing parts of warframe it lets you
turn your bolt or assault rifle into a
critical hit factory on one mission then
swap in new mods for tons of radiation
damage on the next there are countless
combinations of enemies mission types
and tile sets and learning to mod your
equipment for each prevents warframe
from ever getting stale I'm reminded of
all things of the matrix the more I
learn warframes mod system and all of
its systems really the more powerful I
feel what is he doing he's beginning to
believe gaining more power in loot based
games is nothing new but warframe
doesn't automatically increase numbers
for you it teaches you how to do it
yourself
of course like neo you can also dodge
bullets and of course like neo
eventually you won't have to
what I'm saying is that despite the
presence of RNG item farming and some
archaic free-to-play tedium warframes
grind as nuanced warframes grind is fun
to learn by handing the reins of the
power fantasy over to you Digital
Extremes
acknowledges that you are an intelligent
player capable of dictating your own
definition of improvement
[Music]
this is mark rosewater he's head
designer of Magic the Gathering and has
been since 2003 even if you're not into
magic or for that matter collectible
card games mark is one of the more
insightful people when it comes to game
design in general a few years ago he
coined the term lenticular design it's
taken from lenticular images those
pictures that change depending on the
angle you see them from mark use this to
describe systems that are simultaneously
simple to the beginner but more advanced
to the experienced player I know that
sounds like a paradox but bear with me
because it's actually at the heart of
many great modern games take overwatch
for example many of its characters are
lenticular heroes my favorite example is
tracer - the beginning player she has
teleportation powers that make her very
hard to hit - the veteran she's a great
skirmisher someone who can pest her
enemy groups with little intention of
actually killing them she can buy time
for the rest of her team tracer is
lenticular because in this case neither
the rookie nor the veteran are wrong
both philosophies are viable in their
own way it's only through time and
experience that you'll see her from a
different albeit more useful angle
warframes characters or frames are a
prime example of this philosophy each of
them has an obvious theme from embers
fire attacks - mags use of magnetic
abilities then there's rhino a frame
that relies on tanking and brute force
those are all these surface level
attributes and likely the factors that
will help new players decide which
frames to use these are also the
characteristics that make experimenting
with each of the current 39 characters
so fun veteran players however will see
the nuance in their ninjas take mags
polarizability in earlier missions it's
an effective way to do decent crowd
damage it's obvious it's satisfying and
new players will just get it if you use
the right mods though polarize becomes
an extremely useful power in high-level
missions it damages shielded enemies and
reduces the protection of armoured
Marines
it also replenishes the shields of any
allies to touch it
here's another example this is Frost a
warframe based around ice powers the
last ability he learns is called
avalanche which first freezes then
shatters enemies in close proximity to
the beginner this is his most attractive
ability and they wouldn't be wrong to
use it against enemy groups season
warframe players however will know that
in the late game frost is best used as a
defensive character specifically with
his snow globe ability it creates a
protective dome around the frame and his
allies and becomes a major asset in
defense missions and difficult boss
fights I could go on for hours about
more of this multifaceted character
design but I really don't want to spoil
the discoveries you'll have on your own
the last thing I'll say is that the
excitement of this lenticular depth
doesn't wear off in the later hours in
fact it's somehow the opposite Digital
Extremes has this talent for making
warframe more intriguing the more you
play you'll get to the point where you
have a 10 character rotation and a
variety of loadouts for each mission
type it feels like the game is rewiring
your brain with each new scenario it
throws at you this dependence on
colorful heroes with hidden depth is
becoming more prevalent by the year
successful games such as Rainbow six
siege apex legends and overwatch are all
proof of that and if developers haven't
already looked to warframe for
inspiration they should it's a veritable
iceberg of lenticular design and a
shining example of deceptive simplicity
this isn't to say warframe is not flawed
though in fact I wish the devs would
extend this two-sided design to other
areas as well as I said before the
complexity and learning are a huge part
of the games charm but sometimes that
complexity is less of a funnel and more
of a wall about five percent of my time
with warframe hasn't actually involved
playing the game it's consisted of
skimming through wiki's and forums some
objectives are too vague some crafting
materials too hidden for me to call it
clever
sometimes it feels as if warframe uses
complexity just because it can now I'm
not saying Digital Extremes should
explain each and every little thing to
the player but I do think the player
base would benefit if this
studio found ways to ease newcomers into
a few more of its intricacies a more
hands-on modding tutorial for example or
a simple prompt saying focus on clearing
the star chart most of the game will
unfold from there these would do wonders
for rookie players and more players are
only going to benefit everyone involved
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's telling that it's taken me this
long to address the free-to-play
elephant in the room
I rarely felt the need to spend real
money and when I did I didn't regret it
forgive my hyperbole here but more than
any game I played warframe feels like a
partnership between the developers and
me I was happy to give them money I was
happy to support the studio in this
ongoing endeavor there's an example
highlighted in no clips documentary that
perfectly sums up Digital Extremes views
on monetization when the studio released
koo bros the game's canine combat
companions it allowed you to pay real
money for randomized fur patterns and
appearances upon seeing that one player
had pulled that metaphorical lever over
200 times the team realized that had
created a slot machine they promptly
pulled the feature to prevent further
excessive gambling
so in essence Digital Extremes pulled a
micro transaction feature because one
player had used it too many times
Digital Extremes has done so many things
it did not need to do it added to open
worlds to a game that previously relied
on rapid fire missions
it allowed talented community artists to
sell their own armor sets during the
week I began to write the script the
team released night wave a series of
daily and weekly challenges framed as an
in-game radio show there's even a twist
in the mid game hours that
single-handedly changed my perception of
what exactly warframe is but the
community is surprisingly great about
not spoiling this so I'll honor that
here and that's as good an example as
any to character as warframes community
like any group dedicated to something
they love it has its occasional sore
spots but get good mentality in
particular rears its ugly head in the
late game hours but take one trip to the
warframe forums ask for help through the
in-game chat jump into Digital Extremes
dev stream a bi-weekly show that's
coming up on its one hundred and twenty
sixth episode at each and every turn
warframe emphasizes cooperation between
players developers Tenno Jen artists and
YouTube creators alike the theme song
for the recent Fortuna update sums this
up perfectly we all lift
gather
[Music]
we're frame as many things it's a case
study for community involvement
it's a paragon for free-to-play
standards it's a master class in
multi-faceted design and now at the end
of my video
there are countless things I wish I
could have touched on but I'll end by
saying this there is no wrong time to
start playing warframe in fact I would
say now is the best time with more
studios joining the free-to-play scene
and even more seeking balance in their
progression systems warframe is the game
we should be looking to it began as a
product of what games were but has since
become an example of what games can be
and its age doesn't make it antiquated
or obsolete warframes
age makes it a monument and it's time we
all started paying attention